this movie didn't seem like it tried too
hard so I'm not gonna try too hard in my
review I'm going to give you my thoughts
in and out really quick less than five
minutes let's do it
so 65 is a boring slog of an action
action drama sci-fi film Adam Driver
plays this pilot from another world he's
hauling a bunch of people who are in
cryo he gets hit by this meteor
no asteroid the ship crash lands on this
planet there's one Survivor so he and
this one Survivor are gonna Traverse
this alien world that happens to be
Earth 65 million years ago which I
always found was weird that it was shown
in the trailer that would have been an
awesome reveal I remember watching the
trailer being like that could be a
Planet of the Apes style reveal at the
end of the film and after watching the
movie it still could be it tells you in
text in the title of the movies like by
the way this is Earth 65 million years
ago would have been way cooler to have
it be called 65 and have some sort of
red herring rope-a-dope thing going on
like oh I'm hauling 65 passengers the
audience is like oh that's why it's
called 65 because even the dinosaurs in
here I recognize some of them but there
are some like I don't know what that
dinosaur is granted not a paleontologist
but I'm just saying there were some I
didn't recognize so have the ones that
are less recognizable be the main threat
and at the end have a T-Rex an audience
can be like oh oh 65 million years right
all right based on the film on what it
did do
um they walked that happened which you
could have work the premise of the film
is that Adam Driver finds this little
girl the sole survivor of this crash
this girl reminds him of his daughter
and so he's gonna take her to safety
right it's pretty historic Last of Us
which does show us two things one this
movie could have worked two there's a
show out there and a game for PS5 PS4
and PS3 all the same game that do it
better you do get some of the ooh
dinosaurs are coming pew pew shoot
action but you don't have have that
character development and that character
attachment that makes you care about the
plight that they're in it's so funny a
sci-fi movie about people traversing the
dangerous lands of prehistoric Earth
filled with predators and dinosaurs just
felt like a slog it felt like Randall's
impersonation of Lord of the Rings Two
Towers and clerks too yeah two towers
not Fellowship because there is that
occasional side step funny enough
talking about the last of us I could
actually go for video game adaptation
for this because it looked like a video
game his weapon looks like it's from a
video game looks like something out of
Destiny or Halo the last big monster
fight I'll call it a boss fight and this
movie is absolutely from a video game
shoot the monster wound the monster over
the thing that's gonna hurt the monster
and then you kill them I'm like this is
the Legend of Zelda or metroid fight
bust out the Chrono scepter and let's
have ourselves a good time anyhow it was
a slog it was boring shocking given the
content and subject matter after
watching it I was like 65 stands for 65
million years which is how long this 90
minute movie feels this is a film that
on paper has all the makings of great
Intrigue and uses none of it it's the
kind of film I'm not gonna remember not
in T minus one day yep already forgot
I'll ask you what your favorite and
least favorite dinosaur films are
Jurassic Park if that's your favorite
well that's a cheat but it's absolutely
a correct answer but whatever there
whatever you think comment below let me
know and as always if you like what
you've seen here and you want to see
more click right here to say more
[Music]